well Donald Trump really needs some kind
of accomplishment in his presidency or
at least something that he could
realistically call an accomplishment
since becoming president of the United
States and if you went only by some of
the excited headlines on right-wing
media yesterday you might have thought
that Donald Trump got a legislative
accomplishment the travel via band
version 3 we had travel travel ban
version 1 which failed travel ban
version 2 which failed and if you
understood the headlines yesterday to
mean that the Supreme Court says travel
via ban version 3 is on then you might
have thought that Donald Trump got that
legislative accomplishment but he didn't
because what the Supreme Court did
yesterday is say that the travel ban can
be enforce while lower courts hear legal
challenges and that is the key phrase
pending legal challenges the Supreme
Court yesterday ruled that Donald
Trump's ban on six travelers from six
majority Muslim countries can go into
full effect pending legal challenges
Trump now has what sounds like an
accomplishment to some people but it is
really not because the Supreme Court
said nothing yesterday about whether the
travel ban is legal what the Supreme
Court said yesterday is merely the
travel ban can be on Wilde the lower
courts start to sort out the legality
they stopped the preliminary injunction
period nothing was said by the supreme
court about the underlying
constitutionality of the content of the
travel ban nothing was said about the
legality of the travel ban all that has
happened is until the legality is
determined the travel ban is on for
people from these mostly middle-eastern
but a couple of other countries as well
North Korea and Venezuela now it is true
that to grant a preliminary injunction
you do need to consider the likelihood
of success of the law eventually but by
saying that we are stopping the
injunction
the Supreme Court has said nothing more
than we have no idea what the result of
the legal challenges will be some legal
experts are saying that this decision
suggests that when the specific legal
challenges end up back at the Supreme
Court which in all likelihood they will
the Supreme Court will rule in favor of
the Trump administration I say let's
wait and see because that hasn't
happened yet and on the legality to two
major legal arguments right those saying
that this is totally legal say simply
the president has full authority to
regulate immigration however he wants
period that's one side of this argument
the counter-argument is well hold on it
is illegal to discriminate on the basis
of nationality when issuing visas and
that is exactly what Donald Trump's
travel ban would do and we do have I
mean the you know I'm against the travel
ban politically I'm against the travel
ban from a national security standpoint
because the countries are on the list
are not the countries that have actually
sent people to do a to commit attacks in
the United States and I have a long list
of reasons why I'm against it but there
does appear to be a conflicting legal
basis for what ultimately is going to
probably be decided by the Supreme Court
we do not know what will happen yet but
it's very funny how if you go just by
the headlines you might think wow
victory the travel ban is on it's legal
no it's just on for right now until the
legality is sorted out maybe you can
call it a temporary victory Trump
administration and who knows how this
will turn out I mean my sense is that it
is well within the purview of the
president doesn't mean it's good policy
but we'll have to wait and see do you
think it will be found legal eventually
I think so I I could say with more
confidence that it would ultimately be
found illegal but I I do like like I
said there is case law rather there is
US law statutory law on both sides of
this and it could be a while until we
figure it out and in the background
remember the entire thing was supposed
to be a temporary 90 day ban well I
think the first one was but this is our
travels and what isn't right okay all
right well that it
at least explain I wonder if we figured
out by now what the hell is going on
though there were that that was not
meant to be indefinite no doubt about it
okay so not really the victory that
right-wing media has been touting this
to be the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership